عندما أرى شيئًا ما في الأخبار أو عندما
أرى شيئًا ما يحدث من حولي ، فأنا
أحاول
مساعدتهم قدر الإمكان عندما
يقول الناس أنك تأخذ الأمر
بأيديكم كما لو كان الكثيرون يقولون "سأذهب"
في الخارج في احتجاجات أو أتصل
بالمشرعين ولكنك تقوم بالاختراق بشكل صحيح ، أعني
دعنا نقول أنك تتصفح موقع
Reddit فقط وترى شيئًا
يخاف الناس بشأن بعض
ممارسات الشركات التي نحاول الدخول إليها ومن
ثم العثور على المعلومات التي  يمكن استخدامها
ضدهم ثم قلب ذلك ،
هل يمكنك أن تعطيني بعض الأمثلة ، نعم أنا
جاهز منذ بضع سنوات ، هناك
ورقة الشركة حول الكعكة
وهناك الكثير من الشهادات حول أن أعضاء المجلس
هم هنا الأشخاص الذين
يؤذون جسديًا  إنهم يؤذونهم عاطفيًا
جيدًا ، يمكنك المضي قدمًا ومحاولة
اختبار الصفوف مقابل ذلك ، افعل هذا وذاك
لكنهم ما زالوا يفعلون ما
يفعلونه ، لذا بدلاً من ذلك ، يمكنك المضي قدمًا
ومعرفة كيفية الوصول إلى
شبكتهم  عندما تجد بريدًا إلكترونيًا
تجدهم ما تفعله به
يخبئ المستندات عبر الإنترنت ، فهي
متوفرة فقط الشركة نفسها
لم تعد حقًا ما تشعر
به عندما يكون لديك حق الوصول إلى شيء
ما كمخترق لا يجب أن يكون لديك
حق الوصول إليه  في المرات الأولى ،
كان الأدرينالين مليئًا بالأدرينالين في المرة الأولى
عندما تعود
إلى أجهزة الكمبيوتر الخاصة بأصدقائك في أي مكان وأنت تعلم أن
تخدع كل شيء وتطلق النكات عليها
، وأن تسرق نوعًا من الله مثل
الاستمتاع بالكمبيوتر أي شيء في
نهاية المطاف إذا بدأت في العمل مع الشركات
تقوم بعمل خوادم هناك الكثير مع وجود
فاتورة أكثر بكثير من الصحفي لأنك الآن
تعلم أن هناك شيئًا ما لديك
يمكن أن يكون خطيرًا للغاية
بالنسبة لك ولهم في الوقت الحاضر أنت تعلم
أنه نعم لقد فعلته
ومن ثم يبدأ العمل
حقًا  لأن الوصول
إلى المحيط هو نصف
المعركة فقط لتكون قادرًا على زرع جبل
لن يكون حارًا
وسيخضع لرادار أي نوع  منتج الأمان
الذي يعرفونه أنه هو المكان
الذي تبدأ فيه اللعبة الحقيقية ، كم عدد
الشركات التي قد تقول أنك تجلس
فيها الآن ، أعني أنني ربما
سأمرر أنواعًا من الآلاف لاقتحام
شركة حتى لو كنت لا تتفق
معها  ما يفعلونه أو ما
يمثلونه من
أجلك يمكن أن يتم إهمالهم لفترة طويلة ،
هل تشعر بالخوف أو بجنون العظمة من أن
ذلك قد يحدث لك ،
أعني تمامًا أنك تعلم أن
شيئًا ما قد يحدث في النهاية
سيتعين على المرء أن يدفع مقابل ما يفعله  لقد انتهيت
ولكن أثناء قيامك بذلك ، تعلم
أنك تساعد الأشخاص لا أعتقد حقًا
أنه من الجيد القلق بشأن ذلك